أجنبي
أعتقد أنك تعلم أنه من
مصلحة العائلات فقط محاولة
التبرج وعدم إخبار الكثير من
الأسرار القذرة حول ما يحدث ،
نعم لأكون صادقًا معها ، إنه على صواب أو
خطأ لا يهمني حقًا
إنه  أعتقد أن ما يفعله يجب أن
يبقيه في الداخل ويحاول حله
بشكل خاص ، إنه أمر خاص ولا
ينبغي له أن يجعله عامًا جيدًا وأعتقد
أنه يجب عليهم الاحتفاظ بمشاكلهم
الداخلية كما تعلمون لأنك لا
تعلن عن عائلتك  مشاكل مع
أشخاص آخرين تعرفهم وأعتقد أن
الآنسة ماركل أو ميركل أعتقد
أنها وراء كل ذلك
وأعتقد أنها حاجز للأسف
معظم الناس يريدون بناء جسر
تبني جدارًا ، نعم أعتقد أنه يجب عليهم
الحفاظ على خصوصية هذه الأمور خاصة
عندما  لديهم مثل هذا الوصول العام كما
تعلم أعتقد أنه يمكن أن
يكون له تأثير سلبي مضاعف على
العائلة المالكة للأجيال القادمة
وأعتقد حقًا أنك تعلم أنه يجب عليهم
وضع هذه الأشياء بجانب  ديهم وفكر حقًا
في ما هو
الأفضل لعائلاتهم ككل وفكر
في أطفالهم وربما وضع
المكاسب المالية جانبًا في الوقت الحالي ولذا
أعتقد أن هناك خطأ في كلا الجانبين
الآن هاري يسير قليلاً أه
علني ولكن هذه هي الطريقة التي يتصرف بها الناس في
الوقت الحاضر وأنت تعلم أنه قال
وداعه إنه يصنع لحظته
العامة وفي نفس الوقت يريد إعادة بناء
الحياة الأسرية أعتقد أنه بنى لنفسه
تحديًا كبيرًا لكنني لا أعتقد أن عائلته
منه  لا يقدر بثمن
، أعتقد أنه سيعرف ما إذا كان لديهم
انقسام دائم سيحدث
هذا سيحدث ، وأعتقد
أنه ربما كان
يندم على السير في هذا الطريق لكنه لن
يعرف أبدًا حتى يفعل ذلك وهذا هو
نوع الرجل  هو